faux dit moi toi quand tu étais petit
était pas ramasseuse de balle si
aventuriste était ramasseur de balles
ouais tu ferais écoute a échappé mais
non c'est bon cd et terrorisés par les
plus grands des bons petits os jeu
tennis et tout et on était obligé
derrière ces balles c'est vrai que quand
tu étais petit on t'appelait at il a
peut-être mais c'est vrai qu'on a vue de
changer dix fois l'établissement
seulement ouais on en était au cachot il
paraît n'ont pas caché pas les
questionnons se foutait on officier
enfermé à clef ouais voilà dans une
pièce et quand tu t'énerves est un peu
forcément sévèrement calmez vous mais
vous êtes katakana non non non tout
jeter de l'eau froide dessus c'est vrai
oui pour calmer a hypothéqué tout est là
la seule réponse finalement à cet
isolement social c'est qu'à l'époque
c'est là qu'a commencé à te dire je
serai célèbre je saurai ces lettres
c'est la voilà devant des salles est un
rendez vous pouvez qu'elle colle avec
thor quoi c'est ça non mais c'est à
l'école j'ai pas changé d'avis ouais je
suis effondré mais c'est marrant tête et
rebelles très jeune finalement non mais
c'est à dire c'est mm par an mais
j'étais allergique
on m'a mis à l'école j'ai commencé un
examen purulent ne réalisera pas jusque
là avec des contes et des délais je
passe le bac 3 jours après guéri 1 tu
vois et l'âge de 15 ans tu décides de
t'inscrire dans un cours d'art
dramatique et or là il ya deux versions
quand on lit des articles ont été écrits
sur toi ou les interviews il y en a où
tu dis tu es parents étaient d'accord et
d'autres utilités parents ne s'est pas
d'accord alors il sait d'accord ou pas
d'accord des parents ils m'ont forcée du
30 janvier et alors j'étais inscrit zubi
et là tu as commencé à traîner à saint
germain c'était à la fin des fins des
années 60
ouais un milieu des années c'est tant
mieux les années 60
si j'imagine si tu étais très très très
très jolie déjà quoi et c'est là que tu
as rencontré ta première famille
d'adoption
c'est la bande de jean pierre kalfon
waits fuji oui ben oui les bas des
hippies ça se passe et comment cette
époque alors bien dit faisons la caméra
explore le temps que la candidate
très bien à quoi tu occupes toi tu es
journées s'est libérée oui et on est
sorti de la très détendue tu sais quoi
pour fédérer alors alors on se
libérerait des des idéologies bourgeoise
un premier point donc par exemple est un
aveu qui voulait faire un enfant qui on
est et c'était une bonne extrêmement
convivial parce que vous suivez de
l'apostolat libération sexuelle dont il
fallait quand même ça c'est mes
semblables of peace and love bloquer la
grande route
et comme on avait pas mal de matelas
comme ça bon et alors un jeu il y en a
deux qui disent qu'ils vont faire un
enfant à la consulta peu la communauté v
et commence il appellera and on
l'appellera passé bourges a donné un nom
très en profondeur
tu dis à l'époque j'ai beaucoup traîné
un coup j'étais entretenu par un mec un
coup il y avait un copain qui me prêtait
du pognon se fait beaucoup de courses à
combien vont se libérer
j'avais à coeur de me libérer mais oui
c'est à dire qu'on avait un système de
sécurité fonctionnent entre nous comme
personne avait tapié du qu'on peut y ait
pas d'impôt l'ont chargé comme ça alors
et c'était genre combler lé 13 s'emballe
bon alors tu m'invites aline et ben oui
tiens j'ai pas tu n'attends qui pourrait
me faire vous fait sa vamp is a man
c'est comme ça que tu vois on partageait
tous tu veux mon parti j'ai vraiment
vraiment tout mais c'était pas le truc
vista je me sens très bien passée
c'était
on était en train de changer le monde
comme ça ne l'oublions pas est ce que le
monde nous a changés et actuellement
nous a changé certains d'entre nous oui
non non jamais il ya une phrase que son
extraordinaire de toi tu dis à l'époque
j'étais un petit animal sexuelle jolie
place est vraiment être assez joli mais
un rongeur un petit papier à présent un
petit avec mais c'est que ça veut dire
quoi je ne sais pas j'étais déjà grand
dam et ce sans même animal changer
sexuelle oui c'était très partage
oui tu as peur du sida aujourd'hui away
peur peur peur peur dont l'enfant oui
quand même
enfin bon oui à l'époque mais aussi sa
résidence était la grande différence à
sa fête on paie cela oui alors tu t'en
vas
de quoi je vais pas du tas bruche que tu
t'en vas quitter voit rien contre
l'hépatite à ces faits publie un bon tu
sais qu'il ya un autre truc maintenant